does fat-shaming work argued by many
people come for it fat shaming doesn't
need to end needs to make a comeback
some against it we know that being
overweight isn't good for us now I'm not
gonna definitively answer this question
but one thing that I can tell you about
fat shaming is that it can make your
wallet fat if you're willing to throw
out all your morals and ethics we're
about to take a journey and down a very
strange road of basically targeting
women's insecurities to make them pull
out their wallet and buy a product so
here we go let's jump into it hey I
finished editing this and then I
realized I hadn't really set up what
you're about to see so this is a sales
letter
this is copywriting 101 and it's how a
lot of people are selling products on
the internet right now if you click like
on a sidebar ad or something like that
you'll get typically something like this
it tries to use very heavy emotional
call-outs to try to get you to buy a
product
these range from legitimate to
illegitimate I think you'll find out
pretty quick which type this one is
Milly I need to stop my husband rolled
onto the cold sheets next to him he let
out a frustrated sigh and stared blankly
at the ceiling shocked and Confused I
asked him what was wrong he closed his
eyes and that out of breath I'm sorry
I did I I'm sorry I just can't have sex
with you when you're off in another
world it doesn't feel right I love you
but something is wrong and we need to
fix it soon because it's destroying our
marriage I immediately burst into tears
because he was right I was living in
another world a world in which I was so
maybe you can't tell it's all about
targeting women who feel overweight and
well that's who they target for their
little program I felt so flabby I
refused to look at myself in the mirror
after I got out of the shower I think
it's so funny sometimes how people get
outraged on Twitter for like the dumbest
stuff but they never get mad about
this kind of thing this sales letter
starts with the woman's husband refused
to have sex with her because she's too
fat oh my gosh alright so I'm just gonna
jump through a lot of this because
it'sit's one of these things that's
really long it's basically a long sales
letter on eventually selling you on a
thyroid cure which supposedly a leading
hormone expert and doctor created it's
called meta factor with iodine and it
costs two three hundred dollars
so basically if you're tired of your
husband not wanting to have sex with you
it's because you're fat and you need to
pay $300 for this leading hormone
experts thing it's not your fault look
it even says you know it's not your
fault I thought I was doing everything
right I was eating a healthy diet
exercising regularly
I even meditated a few times a week I
was only 42 so it was not normal to feel
like this and the idea behind this is to
make you feel like oh I I with this I
feel like I'm eating healthy I feel like
I'm exercising I'm not losing weight and
then this sales letter swoops in and
says oh it's just because you're missing
this little supplement or whatever this
meta Factor for $300 they prey on your
insecurities oh your your husband's not
gonna want to have sex with you if
you're fat and ugly and you just like
slouch and around all the time
nah you need a little supplement from a
world-leading hormone expert and who is
that world leading hormone expert that's
ready to come in and cure you well it's
doctor Zane Stirling now what's another
word for a leading hormone expert well
you might think it's an endocrinologist
someone who studies the endocrine system
but Zane Stirling is not an
endocrinologist no he's a chiropractor I
don't think I have to remind you of this
but chiropractors are not medical
doctors they want to be medical doctors
that's why a lot of them used the prefix
doctor in their name to make you think
oh this guy this guy sounds like a
doctor he's got docked in front of his
name but he's not actually a medical
doctor and he certainly is not he's not
an endocrinologist is you know so why
are they calling him a world-leading
hormone expert oh my gosh look at this
Rosina grew up in Boise and graduated
from the Boise State University then he
went to Palmer College of Chiropractic
in 1985 what does that have to do with
your thyroid nothing at all but
apparently his unique background makes
him see things differently from regular
doctors and look if I were honest if
someone were like doing surgery on me I
wouldn't want someone who saw things
differently from other doctors I don't
know about you I wouldn't I wouldn't
want that like I'm an engineer by
training that means I see things
differently from doctors that means you
shouldn't come to me for dr. things I
mean it's kind of incredible they're
basically backing a chiropractor who's
supposed to cure your endocrine problems
because you're fat and your husband
doesn't wanna have sex with you if that
is what you understood out of all this
you're basically caught up so I mean
that's pretty much it I just wanted to
call it this absurdity not to mention I
wanted to prep you for my exciting
product that's coming out sometime in
2021 and actually created a video for
you for it that I'm premiering right now
Hey don't you try to be in fat
tired of nobody wanting to have sex with
you
well now everything's gonna change
thanks to a hidden now discovered secret
formula this is just one of our many
happy customers some have complained
that their mental cognition has gone
down and that might be because of the
Himalayan paint thinner we include in
every single capsule but then again
would you rather be stupid or fat I'm
Derrick and I'm satisfied with the super
x-factor product incredible is the word
I would use to describe it people ask me
all the time Stephen how that did you
pull this one off and I always tell him
by assembly and great team like this
right here is dr. Yvonne Alana [ __ ] dr.
Yvonne Alana [ __ ] is a world-leading
expert and doctor no he's not a medical
doctor per se but he did get his
doctorate in sociology so that's pretty
much the same thing right but before we
get too much in the weeds on the science
or who exactly is formulating these
weight loss products let me remind you
exactly why you came to me because
you're rotund righta
and when you wrote on rotund you need a
way out paint thinner and I'm offering
it to you Himalayan paint thinner for
298 dollars in a little bit of cocaine
the answer can be yours
[Music]